avec notre éditorialiste politique
alexis poulain bonjour alexis heureuse
de vous retrouver en ce lundi matin pour
votre édito politique alors qu'est ce
que cette affaire signifie pour les
républicains et pour la république en
marche
est ce que c'est une réorganisation des
appareils ou un simple accord local
alors ça voudrait être maquillée comme
un accord local mais il faut voir que
cet accord a été annoncé d'abord par le
premier ministre jean castex qui a volé
la politesse à renaud muselier d'eau on
voit bien qu'il ya là quelque chose qui
se passe au niveau des appareils avec
cette volonté affichée inde emmanuel
macron de briser les grands partis il
l'a fait à gauche de l'intérieur et il
voudrait maintenant le faire à droite
en scindant les républicains entre ceux
qui sont prêts à rejoindre une nouvelle
majorité présidentielle pour porter sa
nouvelle candidature pour 2022 et ceux
qui souhaiteraient défendre l'opposition
le parti d'opposition les républicains
garder les valeurs
l'idée simple c'est que paca la région
est un test pour le national sophie
cluzel donc a été poliment de on lui a
demandé de retirer sa liste au profit de
renaud muselier
d'habitude on fait ça au deuxième tour
une fois qu'on sait qu'on doit faire
alliance contre leur assemblée nationale
s'ils le souhaitent des politiques en
présence est de faire barrage aux
rassemblant nationale là on le fait en
amont donc on voit bien que c'est une
liste d'alliance de gouvernance qui veut
dire qu'il ya une compatibilité entre
les républicains et la république en
marche
ça n'a évidemment c'est un scandale au
sein de l'appareil
les républicains et auprès des militants
est ce que c'est un accord selon vous
perdant perdant pour muselier et cluzel
et que vont faire les républicains leurs
militants et quelles conséquences pour
thierry mariani et le rassemblement
national
oui alors du côté du rassemblement
national jordan bardella a immédiatement
dit écoutez vous les républicains de
coeur historique venaient travailler
avec nous nous défendons les mêmes
valeurs
eric ciotti disent
également dans une interview à valeurs
actuelles que la seule différence entre
leurs ascendants nationale et les
républicains c'est que les républicains
sont un parti de gouvernement
donc on voit bien qu'il ya en ce moment
comme le disait edouard philippe la
poutre cette fameuse poutres de la
recomposition politique qui travaillent
et qui travaille énormément
il y à un conseil national du bureau
d'investiture des républicains mardi qui
risque d'être extrêmement houleux où
christian jacob va devoir défendre la
ligne d'opposition du parti des
républicains
or rose au lit et un de ses amis donc
l'idée de lui retirer l'investiture
n'est pas facile mais ce choix qui est
celui local de renaud muselier engage
tout un parti avec l'idée de brouiller
davantage les pistes et c'est évident on
va parler maintenant des républicains en
marche d'ailleurs les deux logos ont
tout à fait ensemble à l'air eux-mêmes
et derrière c'est le rassemblement
national qui évidemment va incarner
l'opposition de droite c'est un cadeau
qui est fait là en réalité par sophie
cluzel et renaud muselier à thierry
mariani qui est lui candidate du fn en
paca et au delà de ces régionales est ce
que là est la préfiguration d'une
scission celle et l air ou au ps avant
2022 est plausible
les centristes de chaque formation
ferait donc bloc pour soutenir un second
mandat de d'emmanuel macron oui
clairement c'est la stratégie assumée de
la part du président de la république et
de ce qu'il reste de la république en
marche même s'il ya des dans chaque
partie des gens qui qui sont contraints
cette recomposition mais on voit bien
que l'idée de dépasser la république en
marche qui est un parti qui n'a pas su
s'ancrer dans les territoires d'ailleurs
ce n'est pas pour rien qu'une ministre
candidate en provence alpes côte d'azur
retire sa candidature pour les
républicains donc en marche que connaît
très bien ses faibles chances d'en
laisser des élections intermédiaires les
municipales ont été une claque
électorale gigantesque et les régionales
pourrait être la même chose d'où ces
jeux d'alliances qui facilite la tâche
des manuels mâcon en accélérant
finalement le pourrissement des grands
partis de la politique française
il joue au chamboule-tout avec
l'organisation politique
il y avait le ps les républicains le
rassemblent nationale et puis d'autres
formations mais là on voit bien que son
but est d'aller chercher ce qui pourrait
soutenir une nouvelle plate forme
programmatique le en même temps le
dépassement est dépassé le cas de la
république aux marchandises en voilà
les progressistes de tous les partis
puisque c'est ainsi qu'il s'appelle
peuvent nous rejoindre au sein de la
république en marche mais pour autant à
la république en marche certains voient
cette alliance avec les républicains
d'un mauvais oeil en disant que viennent
du parti socialiste et que ça va devenir
très compliqué et ce en même temps il
faudra l'éclaircir donc il y à là
effectivement un éclaircissement
politique un jeu un jeu dont on va voir
finalement qui reste dans son parti
d'opposition qui est là pour avoir une
place cette alliance en provence alpes
côte d'azur elle ne sort pas de nulle
part
christian estrosi qui est le maire de
nice et monsieur falco maire de toulon
tous les deux oeuvres et pendant des
jours et des jours avec thierry solère
pour arriver à cette alliance donc dans
l'est dans les cuisines de la politique
politicienne voilà ce qui est en train
de se passer
il se trouve que ces partis pourraient
perdre beaucoup de leurs militants et de
leurs soutiens historiques
alors est ce que ça veut dire que la
république en main finalement est
imparti mort-né bien c'est tout le
problème oui de l'absence d'ancrage
territorial de la république en marche
l'absence aussi de grands élus on le
voit bien
même si ce parti est assis sur un trésor
un puisque il a réussi à avoir de
nombreux députés lors des législatives
de 2010 est beaucoup ont quitté depuis
l'appui qu'on marche ont créé des
groupes indépendants agir et autres et
la stratégie aujourd'hui de christophe
castaner portées par d'autres est de
dépasser ce ce cadre là pour aller
chercher de nouveaux talents comme il
les appelle de nouveaux cadres ou des
figures connues au national c'est le cas
bien sûr du maire de nice c'est le cas
maintenant de renaud muselier qui décide
de venir travailler main dans la main
avec la majorité présidentielle et donc
dé facto de devenir membre à part
entière de cette majorité présidentielle
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que les
républicains vont devoir clarifier les
choses rapidement pour éviter d'autres
défections et s'assurer un début de
campagne difficile puisque les candidats
à la présidentielle pour 2022 sont déjà
nombreux il ya exalead bertrand mais qui
ne fait pas l'unanimité au sein des
républicains valérie pécresse aussi qui
pourquoi pas après les régionales
auraient peut être d'autres annonces à
faire et beaucoup d'autres qui attendent
des candidats plus naturels que ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui annoncées
merci alexis c'était donc votre évite
aux politiques ce lundi mais restez avec
nous on va pas
la situation sanitaire mais aussi de ces
manifestations samedi où la cgt a été
prise pour cible par des groupes de
casseurs son représentant met d'ailleurs
en cause
à demi mot les forces de l'ordre écoutez
c'est scandaleux que nos camions et nos
militants et été caillassé le problème
d'abord c'est la sécurisation de la
manifestation puisque les camions ont
été empêchés de dégager la place de la
nation
comment vous analysé cette indignation
puisque je rappelle que la cgt a porté
plainte d'ailleurs pour avoir été prise
pour cible et empêcher d'ailleurs de
circuler par les forces de l'ordre ce
qui aurait envenimé la situation qu'en
pensez vous oui alors il ya une enquête
qui est en cours
évidemment apparemment il ya eu un
imbroglio terrible où la cgt était
clairement prise pour cible selon les
témoignages un des membres du service
d'ordre de la cgt avec des insultes
sexistes racistes l'attaquent des
camions et le problème c'est quand le
cortège syndical a voulu quitter la
place de la nation éloigner ces camions
et ses membres les policiers ont fait
barrage et empêcher les camions de
partir au plus vite donc il ya eu un
malentendu
l'enquète fera la lumière bien sûr sur
les responsabilités de chacun mais ce
qu'on a vu c'est encore une fois un 1er
mai défigurées par des activistes qui
n'étaient pas là pour cette fête
internationale des travailleurs ou ce
rassemblement populaire et familial
d'autrefois et ça devient maintenant un
affrontement entre des forces de l'ordre
en présence extrêmement nombreuse des
casseurs qui sont là systématiquement
maintenant da qu'il y ait une
manifestation et puis des syndicats qui
se sont retrouvés dépassé parce qu'il ne
s'attendait pas à un tel déferlement de
violence c'est parti ce matin pour la
première étape du déconfinement vous et
moi on va pouvoir se déplacer à plus de
10 km fin des interdictions fin des
attestations le chef de l'état qui s'est
exprimé dans la presse régionale
vendredi mais qui a aussi enregistré
cette vidéo pour les français regardent
et même si nous allons progressivement
réouvrir dans un calendrier que je viens
de présenter il faudra jusqu'à cet été
résister ensemble et continuer à
accepter pas simplement les gestes et
les comportements que nous connaissons
mais quelques restrictions pour ralentir
ce virus
tous les français adultes se verront
proposer doses de vaccins d'ici la fin
de l'été
cet engagement sera tenu mais nous
devons aller plus vite plus fort tous
ensemble un plus vite plus fort tous
ensemble il va falloir résister ensemble
visiblement les jeunes en ont un peu
marre puisque les fêtes sauvages se
multiplient des rave parties en bretagne
en bourgogne mais aussi à paris le
message a plutôt du mal à passer
oui je crois que la lassitude et la
fatigue est totale et en premier lieu
celle des soignants qui continuent
d'être sur le pont avec toujours plus de
5800 personnes en réanimation avec
toujours des chiffres qui finalement
suscite la compréhension du corps
médical pour beaucoup de gens mais on a
fermé alors que les chiffres étaient
meilleurs que ceux aujourd'hui et on
ouvre avec un calendrier qui n'a rien de
réaliste finalement sauf si évidemment
la vaccination s'avère être efficace et
qu elle l est les deux heureux sont
suffisantes et efficaces contre de
potentielles variant donc c'est une
course encore un pari même si emmanuel
macron lui se garde de faire tout paris
avec la population française on voit
bien que là il continua calendrier
plutôt dicté par l'économie par le
politique aussi à faire en sorte que sa
gestion de crise si elle peut être
critiqué ne soit pas non plus un fiasco
et un bilan impossible à défendre pour
se représenter en 2022
d'où d'ailleurs très vite il à dire
prendre son bâton de pèlerin et aller
faire le tour des territoires l'idée de
repartir en campagne très vite et de
vouloir qu lance ses deux années de
virus par une séquence politique quitte
à oublier les chiffres pendant un temps
il faudra continuer nous de faire notre
travail de journaliste est de regarder
ce qu'il en est de l'épidémie après la
vaccination
et puis à l'automne puisque beaucoup
d'inconnues demeurent donc on voit bien
que malgré les injonctions à de tenir
bon ensemble ça craque de partout que ce
soit dans les différentes professions
comme infirmière scolaire par exemple
qui vont avoir à gérer les autotests des
enfants sans protocole en disant que
finalement on ne sait pas où on est les
soignants qui continue de ne plus en
pouvoir et puis une jeunesse qui veut
sortir qui veut vivre et qui en a assez
des gestes barrières et des
interdictions à tout va parler des
enseignants et de l'agent
ce retour en présentiel pour les lycées
aujourd'hui et déjà des protestations
contre le maintien des épreuves orales
du bac tu voyais les propos du ministre
hier il faut arrêter d'être obnubilé par
le rôle de l'école dans les
contaminations
c'est loin d'être le facteur principal
alors il faut arrêter d'être obnubilé
par le virus on a un peu mal à le croire
quand on voit aussi que le taux de
vaccination nepad a été un peu surestimé
surévalués par le gouvernement alors
c'est formidable parce que le
gouvernement adore les chiffres en
général et des que les chiffres vont
contre le narratif à la réalité élite et
alternatives qui est proposé par les
différents ministres à ne surtout pas
s'occuper des chiffres finalement le
réel n'a pas d'importance ce que dit
jean michel bancaire sur le rôle des
écoles dans les contaminations il est
prouvé par de nombreuses études encore
récente de la semaine dernière qu'ils
aient louis fermer les écoles a un sens
pour faire halte au virus
mais voilà la réalité que jean michel
blanquer on veut sortir c'est aller on
ouvre ses l'ordre du président tout va
bien vous testerez les enfants à son
protocole on va improviser un de toute
façon et on n'a pas commandé
l'administration française n'a pas
commandé de purificateurs d'air ou des
solutions faciles direct rapide pour les
écoles c'est un peu du cas par cas cette
eau aux régions aux départements de se
débrouiller aux établissements et
derrière il ya ce narratif qui voudrait
que tout va aller mieux parce que la
gestion était formidable et que donc il
faut arrêter de regarder les mauvais
chiffres puisque cela n'existe plus
c'est assez magique c'est la pensée
magique de jean michel blanquer
c'est aussi la limite de cette gestion
par les chiffres d'une épidémie ou d'une
politique nationale puisque derrière on
sait bien que le grand danger le risque
c'est la reprise ou non de l'économie
nationale avec un shop sociales et
économiques d'importance
une fois passées les mesures
liberticides et la mise en place d'un
fameux pass sanitaire qui sera le débat
qui va aussi nous occuper dans les jours
qui viennent et on en reparlera
évidemment avec vous alexis merci
beaucoup en tout cas d'avoir commenté ce
matin l'actualité politique sur arte
france on se retrouve lundi prochain